hey what's happening guys My Name Is AO
and welcome to episode 13 of game
programming so yesterday we
um took a look at this pixel and we
actually got it to to work properly and
this time um you know today I promise
that I teach you guys how to uh how to
make a timer and how to actually keep
track of um of things that don't
necessarily have to happen in every CPU
cycle like the update method um because
obviously that needs to happen 60 times
a second so not like as much as possible
as second
so that's what that's what we're going
to look at today that's creating a basic
timer um now this is not going to be an
FPS counter it's simply going to be a
timer okay so there's a bit of a
difference um I'll probably do an FPS
counter tomorrow okay there's yeah
you'll see okay so in the run method I'm
in the game. Java class right now in the
run method right just before we actually
begin our wild running Loop so again
what's going to happen is the Once the
game starts once the thread starts the
run method is going to be called and
immediately what's going to happen with
that is it's going to do you know
whatever's here so in this case right
now it's it's just going to jump into
the wild running Loop and just do this
infinitely until we end our game or you
know until we said running equal to
false um so it's not going to go any
further than that if we type something
in here like it's going to do that when
we close our game basically and that's
kind of useless to us but if we actually
put code over here in between the you
know at the start of the method it's
going to execute this code once and then
it's going to go to the while running
Loop and loop whatever's in those
brackets so when we first start our game
when we first initialize our game we
want to actually set a few variables and
create a few variables the first
variable that we're actually going to do
is create a variable to actually store
time so there is a a way a format to
actually measure uh the the the the
systems time so in terms of um you know
almost like to to measure is like every
CPU cycle so that we actually know you
know which point in time our computer is
at um and then we can use that to for
example time how long it takes us to
render something um ensure that we don't
render anything above a certain number
per second um all sorts of all all sorts
of uses for that so um yeah but we
actually need to retrieve you know that
variable that actually holds the time so
it is a long okay um because it's a very
uh long
guess this cuz of a very long thing
obviously the long is um the the long
variable is just a very very very big
number that um is very um you know long
and big and stuff um we're just going to
call it uh last time because it's is
going to be like our last time you'll
see see what I mean in a second I'm
going to say that equal to system do
Nano
time um now there's two way to there's
two ways to measure this there's system.
current time Millis which is like the
system. current time milliseconds um
that that's in milliseconds this is in
Nan as as you can imagine which is very
very very very very precise and it's
much better to use this than it is to
use Uh current time U milliseconds
although in some cases and in this timer
as well we we will actually be using um
current time uh in millisecs as well as
as narcs so this what this does is first
time we run our game it just sets what
whatever our computer is currently at in
terms of time to this last time variable
now the next thing we need to do is
actually create a double uh or or a
variable for actually
converting um integers uh sorry not
integers for for converting milliseconds
into nanc or actually vice versa
converting nanc into milliseconds so um
I'm just going to um we'll make it final
because we're not going to change it
ever and we're just going to call it um
actually we could change it technically
but um I'll do that in a second it'll be
double and we'll call it NS just that
just stands for nanc that'll be like our
Nano seconds conversion thing and we'll
set that equal to 1 billion so 1 and
then 9 Z 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 UM and then
you know that and we put 0 Z to ensure
that we're actually in double Precision
here and we'll simply divide that by the
number of
um well this isn't that's obviously the
conversion
here but what we want to do is we want
to
um what a good way to put this what we
divided by is is how many times we want
we want to actually run our update
method because you'll see the maths sort
of come together at the end I'm sort of
looking forward here
um the number that we put here which is
going to be 60.0 in our case basically
what this is going to do is when we
actually do divide by Nanos by NS by
this variable um we'll be essentially
setting um you know what I I can't it's
really hard to explain this without
actually having code on the on the
screen for you guys to see it in effect
so I'm just going to continue writing
this right now um the other thing we
need is a Delta variable which again
you'll see in a minute you'll see that
in action in a minute and that's pretty
much all we need so far in the um in the
in you know in the preliminary run
method with you know outside of the
outside of the loop all right um so what
we need to do here is actually create a
variable another long called now and
we're going to set it again to system.
Nano time so now you might be thinking
um you know you've created the variables
they're both equal to the same thing
what's up with that so the deal is when
we first run our program when the game
first opens we retrieve the computer's
current time right uh in in nanocs now
while when we're running obviously by
the time it's completed all these lines
of code and actually gotten to the
running Loop um the system's time is
going to be different cuz it doesn't do
this instantly it does take time even if
it is a very small amount of time it
still does take time now the best way to
actually
um the best way to probably uh
demonstrate this is if I just hit return
here and um just so it gets out of the
method and I actually just run this it's
going to
terminate hang
on
um
so I'll print
now followed
by okay so last time plus
that um and I don't know I'll just do
like a
comma okay so that's going to print the
two variables onto our console and um
over here I'll just call the stop method
so that we actually stop the program
okay so right now you can see that it's
printed two variables over here um and
the this is actually the system time in
nanc I'll zoom in a lot so you guys can
see this this is the first one this is
the second one as you can see the second
one is actually quite a bit larger um
than the first one that's because it's
actually taking time to get from this
variable to this variable okay because
this code gets executed then this code
gets executed then this code gets
executed then this code then we get to
here and we've actually been able to
measure the distance now we can measure
this distance precisely if we simply put
now minus last time and if we measure
that we can be like oh all right it took
that much time that's a very small
number um and in fact I'm not even going
to bother working out what that is in
actual tangible uh measurement like
milliseconds but um that is how that is
that is how long it took um in in NS
okay it took 2,680 NS to actually
complete that operation
um Now using this theory that we can
actually measure how long it takes to do
things we can we can actually um measure
you know the amount of time that we
actually have to spare so if I cut that
and we we get back to our normal um our
normal stuff uh what I can do is to the
Delta variable I can actually add onto
it now plus equals means that I'm
actually just plus equals is the same is
Delta equals Delta plus and then you
know what whatever we put you know what
whatever number we put here um plus
equals does the exact same thing but
it's just it's just a shorter way of
writing
it okay so Delta plus equals now minus
last time here I am again measuring
measuring
um the the the time that it took I'm
okay you get this I assume okay okay
what I'm doing here is I'm adding to
Delta the difference between these two
variables so in other words the time
that it took to get from here to here in
this case um it'll obviously change
later um and then I'll divide it by Nan
our nanc variable now what what this is
going to do
is um again onto Delta it's going to add
on the difference here and it's going to
divide it by 1 billion divid 60 with
which when we actually go over here and
say
while Delta
oops is actually greater than or equal
to 1 which will only happen 60 times a
second because remember we've set 60
over
here
um then we're going to
update so I'll get rid of it here and
we're actually going to just subtract
one from Delta so we we get it back to
zero essentially or um or you know
whatever it is
so read this code analyze it and I'm
sure you'll find out exactly what it
does it's just simple maths so again
what we're doing here is we're creating
a variable actually I'll explain this
Loop thing now what what's going to
happen and let's get rid of actually we
should probably keep stop here we'll
keep the stop method here just because
um that's going to ensure that if we do
get out of this running Lo for some
reason it's going to stop the program
which is which is good
now
okay so I'm so tired today I'm really
sorry guys I I had a huge day today I
can barely understand what I'm writing
here um and I have to like run off to an
exhibition right now as well for art so
well for artwork for my artwork actually
so I probably shouldn't be allowed to
that s and half an hour
um but okay let's try this one more time
so last time is going to be equal to the
computer's current time
our Nan variable is going to calculate
um a value which will be this so that we
can then divide the difference by it to
achieve our Delta variable this now
variable is going to get the current
Loops um current time because what's
going to happen is obviously it's going
to get to the end of this Loop and then
go back and then this now variable will
be updated um oh we actually forgot one
more thing and that's actually to set
last time
equal to now
and again what what that's actually
going to do is um you know after it
after it actually uses now minus last
time it's going to update last time and
then it's going to calculate the time it
takes
to um complete all of this so it's going
to calculate the time that it takes from
us to get um from here all the way back
up to up to here and then it's going to
calculate that distance so um let's do
it let's do it this
way I'll demonstrate it quickly so we'll
create a
bulling called um C we'll set it equal
to
false um then what's going to happen is
at the end we're going to set c equal to
true and then over here I'm just going
to
put if c equal true then let's just
render
um oops
out. print
line then let's just
render um sorry let's just print out
um time
tagen and then we'll
calculate last time minus now
probably okay and we will actually
return
let's just
um let's just exit the program straight
away okay
so um this is temporary code by the way
don't don't bother writing it down I'll
delete it at the end of this episode
um just before it does this
actually I can't oh God okay
so
um
H let's just run
this that's wrong
okay that's cuz it's set this equal to
now let's do that here so if we run this
what it's actually going to do is give
us a negative number
yay cuz it should be now minus last time
again sorry I'm really
tired okay so now we can see that okay
this whole thing to update our game and
to render our game it took us this
amount of time it took us that many what
is that one two
three two
three 5 55 million NCS it took us to
actually render one frame onto the
screen and using that basis we can not
only control how often we update our
game which is going to be 60 times a
second but what we also uh control we
can also figure out that okay if it took
55 million times uh sorry if it took 55
million NCS to actually render one frame
we can be like the game is running at
this many frames per second although
it's not technically that calculation
it's more of a um let's calculate how
many times it can actually render per
second okay so using that basis tomorrow
will actually create that um that uh FPS
counter okay I'm sorry I'm so tired
right now you guys have no clue but um I
did promise one episode per day so take
all this code down and you will be I'll
just delete the stuff we don't need take
all this code down and um and you'll be
sweet so don't
worry yep all right so um I'll see you
guys tomorrow later
[Music]
guys